following the news that station casinos  will demolish two of its oldest  properties one of the women running for  mayor in north las vegas pitching an  alternative plan  let's consider instead of tearing these  properties down  retrofitting them number one for women  veterans and everything that they need  we've never done that  never done that there have been a lot of  facilities that have been erected for  men but we've never done anything for  women  state senator pat spearman a veteran  herself wants texas station to be  donated to support women in the military  she adds that fiesta rancho could be  used as a skilled training center to  help those who are losing their jobs to  technology north las vegas councilwoman  pamela goins-brown who is running  against spearman telling us it is too  early to comment on the topic